It is time for Drew's News.
Pop your news hood
and we'll top off that good news oil.
(Drew gulps loudly)
With me at the desk,
my trusty co-pilot, Ross Mathews.
Hi, everybody, hi!
(audience claps)
Glug, glug, glug.
And I am honored to introduce incredible actors,
writers, comedians,
and together they host the mega hit podcast,
Bitch Sesh, please welcome the ones, the onlys,
Casey Wilson and Danielle Schneider.
Yeah!
(audience claps and cheers)
Hello.
Hi.
I mean, Casey,
you and I over the last few years have made friends.
Yes.
I was lucky enough to have you and June come on
early in the show.
Then Casey came back on the show,
and I got to do her makeup,
which was really fun.
I got right in your face.
I know. I need you today.
I mean, you know, you made me look,
there I am, gorgeous.
Yeah. That's us being intimate girls.
(audience claps)
Cute, and bonding.
Yep, and we geeked out about the Netflix series
called "You",
'cause we were obviously
(audience claps)
somehow drawn to Penn Badgley and his obsessive behavior,
and kind of wondering why
there weren't men obsessing about us the same way.
(Danielle and audience laugh)
I know, why is no one putting me in a basement,
(all laugh)
and trying to kill me?
It's so unacceptable, but we had such a blast together.
And then I went back to my podcast,
I have to tell the story,
to kind of tell Danielle all about what had happened here,
and meeting you,
and we did have a little bit of a mix up.
We had a 'Three's Company' classic.
Yeah, mix 'em upsies.
And we had talked about,
I said that you told Danielle that I loved,
well, how do we put it?
You said-
Well, you know what, here, actually look at this.
It'll help.
This is what happened.
I had the good fortune of doing Drew Barrymore,
but I had so much fun.
We both discussed our love of "You" and Penn Badgley.
Oh, I thought, for just a second, Casey.
(Danielle laughs)
God, this is so embarrassing.
When you said
'We both discussed our love of "You"',
(Casey laughs)
I thought Drew Barrymore knew who I was, and loved me.
Unfortunately,
I meant the number one show on Netflix.
(audience claps and cheers)
Oh it wasn't.
It wasn't you, it was the show, "You".
I know. Danielle thought Casey said that we were talking
about you Danielle, and that we loved you, Danielle.
Yeah.
And it was "You", not you mix up,
and Danielle was crying.
I was crying.
Because Drew was such an icon to me,
and I feel like we've grown up together.
And so to hear she loved me,
I was like, 'Oh my God'.
And then I was like, 'Oh God,
this is so embarrassing, because she doesn't know who I am'.
Oh, well-
It was then-
So hard, but you then reached out,
because you said I have to make it up to Danielle,
and I myself felt terribly again.
She was in full blown, explosive tears,
both thinking that you loved her,
and then finding out you did not actually know her.
I'm not well.
Yeah,
(Ross laughs)
and so it was so upsetting,
and so you came and surprised us.
Yeah. On your Bitch Sesh, like amazing, live show.
Live Show.
You're addressing me, and I'm crying again.
(all laugh)
You love Drew so much,
and our podcast is about The Real Housewives,
and you showed up in a Meredith Marks chain link face mask.
As one does
As one does.
Yes, and it was such a huge moment for me,
and I was so excited,
and I was like, 'Oh my God.
I now know Drew loves me, not "You", but me'.
(all cheer and clap)
And also-
(audience claps)
I might lock you up in a basement.
I'll be in your basement any day, Drew!
(light music)